I'm concerned about the obsession with
the people obsessing too much about the
afterlife,
not just religious people,
but scientists.
It's what I call it,
the afterlife for atheists.
The core of my book is really about
all the cryonics people in the
transhumanists,
in the singular Terry ends
and the extropians and the
people that are going to
upload your mind into a
computer and turn it off.
You know,
ray Kurzweil and all these guys,
you know,
they're,
they're almost gurus when
you go to these conferences,
you know,
it's like we get to live forever.
We are the generation that gets delivered.
They're the generation that's going to
instantiate the daddy in the form of
computational entity as well.
That's right.
I mean,
Kurzweil even has a funny line about that.
Is there a god?
Well,
if there's going to be pretty soon,
as soon as we hit the singularity,
and so I've been to
the singularity summit.
It reminds me of what I was religious.
You know,
I used to be an evangelical,
I went to Pepperdine University,
uh,
which is a church of Christ school.
I was really into it.
And,
uh,
and going to church and all that stuff.
And I get,
I go to the singularity
summit and it's like,
wow,
I'm back in church.
Here's Ray Kurzweil grew up there telling
us we are the first generation that
will live forever.
And you know,
operating gray,
this radical life extension,
the scientists,
you know,
he,
he's on record saying the first
person to live a thousand years is,
is born now,
is this alive now?
Right?
So there's two elements to,
they have an issue that
we can discuss them.
And one is the belief in the existence
of heaven and the other is the positing
of heaven as an Ame.
Yes,
those are interesting.
We related.
So from my perspective from,
so one of the things as
far as I'd be able to tell,
one of the things that allows
us to transform the reality
that's too complicated
to perceive into these
functional low resolution icon,
let's say,
is an aim.
You have to aim right and you
have to aim with your eyes.
And in fact,
we're also extraordinarily good at
detecting how other people aim with their
eyes.
So the question is always,
well where should you aim?
And the answer to that
archetypally I would say,
and biologically for that matter is that
you should aim up because why the hell
would you aim down?
Down is hell.
Right down is where the suffering
is down is where the malevolence is.
So you aim up and
architecturally op is heaven.
And so one of the things that I can't,
it seems to me that there's
some possibility that it
was impossible for human
beings to discover the future,
which is something that
we seem to have done.
Maybe that was pre frontal
extension and that was the,
the expansion of the prefrontal cortex
and its deep wiring with the visual
cortex that actually enabled
us to foresee the future.
Something like that.
I don't know if you can foresee the
future without stumbling upon the idea of
heaven at the same time,
because they haven't,
in that sense,
becomes the best possible
future and you're aiming out,
you're aiming at a better future,
and because you're ending
out a better future,
you're kind of compelled to also
conceptualize at least in principle,
like the platonic ideal of the future.
And so then that future potential
starts to become kind of a reality.
It's something like that.
Yeah,
I think that's a super good point.
My,
again,
my concern about obsessing too much about
the next life as you're going to miss
out on this life,
which is where you live right now.
Uh,
but,
but that's different from aiming at it.
I mean,
you know,
my,
I wrote a book on moral progress,
the moral arc,
they mean for incremental improvements
in civil rights and health and longevity
and,
and ridding ourselves of disease and war.
These are all admirable goals and
we should keep doing that aiming for
something.
And I do like the metaphor up because
maybe it's because we're
a social hierarchical
species.
I think that's why the pyramids,
I believe that.
I think that's what the
pyramids represent with her,
with their gold cap.
Right?
It's
right.
And The Washington monument
does the same thing.
Right?
Or The pyramid of hierarchy
of needs and so on.